بات سلمان ابن عبد العزيز السابعه ملوك
السعوديه بعد انباء عن مالي كان فجر
الجمعه اثر وفاه الملك السابق عبد الله بن
عبد العزيز سلمان من مواليد اخر يوم من
سنه خمسه وثلاثين س مائه والف وهو الابن
الخامس والعشرون للملك المؤسس من زوجته
الاميره حصه بنت احمد السديري رسمت
تسريبات وثائق ويكيليكس عنه سوره تقدمه
على انه حذر في تبني الاصلاحات
كما انه بدا في تلك التسريبات يقرا حسابا
للاجنحه المحافظه والتي لها نفوذ ثقافي
واجتماعي في المملكه ويعد احد اهم اركان
العائله المالكه السعوديه حيث انه حافظ
اسرارها وهو المستشار الشخصي لملوك
المملكه استمر سلمان ابن عبد العزيز امير
منطقه الرياض حوالي نصف قرن وفي اغسطس
الفين وعشره خضع الامير سلمان لجراحه في
العمود الفقري وبعد وفاه الامير سلطان ابن
عبد العزيز ولي العهد وقتذاك في نوفمبر
الفين واحد عشر اصدر الملك عبد الله بن
عبد العزيز امرا بتعيينه وزيرا للدفاع ثم
بعد وفاه الامير نايف ولي العهد وقتذاك
ايضا اصدر الملك عبد الله ابن عبد العزيز
امرا اخر في يونيو الفين واثني عشر
باختياره وليا للعهد وتعيينه نائبا لرئيس
مجلس الوزراء وزيرا للدفاع عرف عنه
اتهاماته والثقافيه حيث انه يمتلك شراسه
من المجموعه السعوديه للابحاث والتسويق
التي تتولى اصدار جريده الشرق الاوسط
واسعه الانتشار و يقول مقربون من الصحيفه
ان له تاثيرا في اتجاهاتها التحريريه